bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous en train de faire que peut-on
attendre du fmi a fait des mois qu'on en
parle c'était vraiment la tente un petit
peu ultime de du liban s'est pour ainsi
dire la dernière chance selon vous
effectivement bonsoir en premier le le
problème se situe au niveau d'une crise
économique très dangereuse qui se passe
au liban spécialement ap le l'évolution
en guinée du 17 octobre 2019 jusqu'ici
il n'y a pas de solution il ya des
problèmes au niveau des services publics
des services fondamentaux de la justice
de l'économie même des éléments
essentiels de la vie et on attend
toujours à cause des dissensions entre
les factions d'aidé des gouvernements du
pouvoir là les partis qui gouverne le
gouvernement de hun sen diable qui qui
fut folle mais ans après appelé la
révolution en 2019 il ya eu le défaut de
paiement en avril 2020 il ya eu tous ces
problèmes et les percussions et
jusqu'ici ce gouvernement n'a pas n'a
pas pu rien faire car il ya eu un
blocage qui a qui a duré à peu près deux
mois et on attend toujours de 1 si vous
voulez un ajustement sur le plan de de
de donner un coup de pouce si vous
voulez on les forme voulue par le peuple
libanais en premier par le fmi par la
communauté internationale par les amis
du liban qui veulent qu'ils veulent
vraiment aider le liban afin de faire
quelque chose pour le peuple libanais
qui souffle actuellement et c'est pas
c'est pas une question théorique c'est
une question pratique c'est une question
dangereuse et stratégiques c'est pour
cela on attend le fmi avec les
les cahiers de charges afin que le
gouvernement pourra adopter un budget
raisonnable
où l'utile c'est de donner un le
lancement à l'économie libanaise et
l'agréable en guinée c'est de donner au
peuple si vous voulez un espoir que les
problèmes au liban pour être petit à
petit résolu surtout rappeler les
élections parlementaires qui vont avoir
lieu en mai prochain alors le fmi à des
cahiers de charges en économie en dans
les affaires sociales en ce qui concerne
l'électricité la réforme du système du
secteur des télécoms et tout ça mais le
problème essentiel reste toujours qui a
dilapidé pour ne pas dire volé
l'argent du peuple libanais qui a volé
l'argent d'année montrent avant de
donner la parole à claude blanchemaison
va on va revenir vers vous dans quelques
instants que le mans je fais on rappelle
que la monnaie a quand même perdu 90% de
sa valeur au liban les trois quarts de
la population basculer dans la pauvreté
la marge de manoeuvre du fmi est ce
qu'il est tout de même élevé parce que
on part de très très loin
le femi en effet est au chevet du liban
depuis le défaut de paiement et la crise
économique a été aussi aggravé par bien
sûr la crise sanitaire comme partout et
puis par l'explosion dans le port dans
le port de beyrouth au mois d'août 2020
explosion qui n'est toujours pas
véritablement élucidées c'est l'un des
problèmes alors le liban a quand même
fait des progrès au cours de ses
différentes missions puisqu'il a pu
faire chiffrer par l'administration
libanaise
l'importance des pertes d'environ 70 à
80 milliards de dollars dit-on et puis
le gouvernement libanais et le
gouverneur de la banque centrale le
célèbre gouverneur qui est qui est en
place depuis 30 ans et qui a une banque
qui n'est pas très transparente et qui
s'oppose à tout à tout examen de deux de
ses comptes et bien il y là il a estimé
et c'est probablement réaliste que pour
relancer la machine économique il
fallait 15 milliards alors comme ça
vient d'être dit par monsieur ce faire
je je crois que actuellement il se passe
quelque chose c'est à dire que les deux
ministres proches du hezbollah wii qui
refusaient de siéger dans le
gouvernement depuis trois mois pourrait
revenir dans le gouvernement parce qu'il
semble que le hezbollah élevés sont
interdits c'est là une très bonne
nouvelle pour les libyens et c'est une
bonne nouvelle et le hezbollah
naturellement ne peut pas prendre une
décision de ce genre et la transmettent
par le biais du président du parlement
qui est assez proche de cette tendance
si
le feu vert n'avait pas été donné à
téhéran donc c'est très intéressant
parce que ça veut dire que quelque chose
a bougé et en effet l'iran n'a pas
intérêt à un effondrement total du liban
disparition du liban par conséquent
cette position a été assouplie et le
premier ministre qui n'avait pas pu
réunir son conseil des ministres
puisqu'il manquait deux ministres dont
une milice des finances qui est très
important depuis trois mois a dit qu'il
réunirait le conseil des miss
d'économiser finances lui apporterait un
projet de budget donc le budget dont on
parlait tout à l'heure devrait être
élaborée mais enfin on ne peut peut-être
pas été élaboré en quelques heures il
faut peut-être un peu de temps et sur
cette base le conseil des ministres
adoptera un budget qui sera déjà quelque
chose et le problème restera en effet
entier c'est pas entre maintenant et les
élections qu'on va faire les réformes de
structure alors ça veut dire que les
réformes de structure ce sera peut-être
on peut toujours l'espérer pour après
encore que le système électoral est
telle que de toute façon au dernier au
résultat il faut respecter les accords
qui faisait accord de partage de pouvoir
entre
président de la république le premier
ministre et le président du parlement et
que par conséquent il ya peu de chances
que la classe politique change beaucoup
après fév élections même si il ya en
effet des mouvements dans la population
pour obtenir des changements alors dans
le fond ce qu'on attend de cette mission
du fmi c'est qu'elle donne un ballon
d'oxygène à ce gouvernement pour lui
permettre de passer le cap des élections
antoine sfeir tout à l'heure vous disiez
voilà on ne sait pas vraiment qui a
dilapidé mais enfin qu'est ce qui nous
garantit que cet argent qui va être
investi aujourd'hui pour soutenir le
liban et bien il va être mieux géré et
qu'on va réussir a justement éviter une
forme de corruption dans ce pays
c'est ça le grand problème et c'est pour
cela la la conférence aids n'a pas pu pu
voir le jour avec en exécution en
application vu qu'il y avait des
conditions alors à paris 1 paris deux
palettes loi y avait pas de condition
s'était ouvert lors il ya déjà des
milliards de dollars qui se sont
écoulées sur le marché libanais alors il
ya pour y avait beaucoup d'argent mais
le problème c'est que cet argent
appartient
aux la destination de cet argent fut
l'économie l'électricité les secteurs
principaux les secteurs vitaux les
services sociaux et tout ça ça n'a pas
été le cas actuellement s'il ya de
l'argent qui va être aussi injecté dans
le système libanais ne par la communauté
internationale bref m 10 ou par toute
autre organisation ou un état ça ne veut
pas dire que l'assainissement économique
et sociale va voir le jour demain alors
c'est un problème concernant être
princesse concernant la composition et
l'esprit dont le pouvoir politique au
liban dans toute cette partie je ne je
ne fais pas de distinction alors c'était
et ça l'est toujours du business
politique du gouvernent le pays il n'y a
pas de contrôle il ya des queues comme
comme monsieur a dit il ya 70 milliards
ou 90 milliards ça ccc le si vous voulez
la faille en guinée alors mais qui en
est responsable et on est responsable on
peut pas avoir une responsabilité sans
responsable on peut pas voir delà de la
corruption ça sent corrompu et
corrupteur c'est le problème c'est que
les élections parlementaires en mai
prochain vont constituer un début de
changement alors c'est trop dire si vous
dire on dit que le peuple libanais et
très arbre a à faire et que les
habilités actuellement à faire un grand
choix afin de faire un grand changement
et vous savez tous que le problème est
monsieur a bien à bien a bien insisté le
problème c'est aussi il a une portée
régionale internationale qu'on peut pas
nier ça il ya des partis politiques au
liban guillon des alliances avec
d'autres et à d'autres axes et c'est
pour cela on est toujours dense où la
reine deviennent alors on allait
les réseaux sociaux même les journaux
liban est tout à leur disque si à vienne
on va avoir un
commencement de rapprochement ou de koar
ou de d'accord alors ça va être si vous
voulez appliquer partiellement sur la
scène libanaise alors ça c'est un pro il
ya une portée internationale
côté local on a bien en tout cas compris
des les enjeux et les difficultés merci
beaucoup antoine sfeir d'avoir été avec
nous